my goal is one shot
and have the animal not take a step i'm
trying to
to make it a humane kill as quick as
possible
[Laughter]
dan has traveled to namibia with a
single mission
to track and kill an african animal
the realities of hunting is you kill
something that's true but personally i
would much rather live free out here
in the kalahari and then die by a single
gunshot wound
he's trophy hunting
we'll get close to the animal i know
we're close when johnny tells me
load up it's one of the most emotive and
controversial sports in the world
i have maybe five seconds to make the
shot
sometimes i'm not quick enough sometimes
i am
it may sound perverse but people like
dan are actually helping to conserve
some of africa's most iconic and
endangered wildlife
here's why
[Music]
images like these create intense debate
around trophy hunting online
worldwide outrage tonight over the death
of cecil the lion
why are you shooting a lion in the first
place shoot him
shoot him right between the ears
yet campaigns and outrage on social
media often only tell part of the story
at the moment
is very one-sided it's very emotional
it's also driven by people that have
more resources than us
they have their hollywood stars they've
never traveled
and came and sit underneath a tree with
these communities and
understand where they are coming from i
can't understand what would motivate
someone to go and want to kill
a lion for fun or any other animal for
fun
there is a narrative that says these
animals are threatened
and rich americans generally are going
out to shoot them of course that sounds
very compelling
but the realities are much more
complicated than that
much media attention focuses on trophy
hunting in africa
but it actually takes place in countries
all over the world
and in many as part of a diverse
wildlife conservation strategy
americans do import the most mammal
trophies
over 30 000 in 2017 alone
but trophy hunting is not driving any
species to extinction
conservation in general is very
underfunded
in africa when it comes to environment
and conservation issues
they are normally at the bottom of each
of the african countries agendas
and hunters can bring in valuable
revenue to fund conservation
and protect against threats such as
poaching
[Music]
trophy fees can average 600 for an
impala
over ten thousand dollars for a lion and
even more for an elephant
with the hunts themselves often costing
more
dan has paid to hunt and kill an oryx
the whole hunting experience is very
challenging and i like that i i live for
challenges
there's a challenge of trying to find
the animal the challenge of getting
close enough to make a
an ethical shot the final thing is when
you pull the trigger
getting the bullet placement correct so
you make a clean ethical kill
[Music]
growing up in texas i've always hunted
but i've never hunted trophies until i
came to namibia
[Music]
namibia where trophy hunting has been
legal since the 1960s
has more wildlife today than at any
point in at least
the past 100 years yet the picture
across
africa is bleak although exact numbers
are subject to debate in just over a
century
elephant numbers have plummeted over 90
percent of black rhinos were lost
between 1970 and 1994
although numbers have rebounded and it's
estimated that lions which are
notoriously hard to count
have been reduced by over 30 percent in
just over a decade
but trophy hunting is not the major
threat facing any of these species in
africa today
the biggest threat to survival of
wildlife in africa is the loss of
habitat
as human populations grow
farming and urban development have taken
up large swathes of land
previously occupied by wildlife
take lions only eight percent of their
historical range remains
and they have reportedly vanished from
15 african countries
and this is where trophy hunting can
actually help
trophy hunting enables governments and
other landowners to maintain
land under a wildlife based use and
therefore reduces those threats of human
encroachment
poaching and other very significant
threats
when marina lamprecht bought this plot
of land in namibia
where dan is hunting it was a cattle
ranch
in an area like this which was
previously a cattle farm
wildlife had very little value above
that of its meat
we now have a very large piece of
dedicated wildlife area
and we fund it through very selective
very sustainable trophy hunting
we'll be back money from foreign hunters
like dan
enables marina to keep this land for
wildlife
it's a very nice quiet morning little
bit of wind
i think it's a nice morning for andy
most people assume that trophy hunting
is
about killing but that's not the part
that i'm looking forward to i enjoy the
stalk i enjoy the challenge of it
and yes you have to take the animal but
that's what funds this operation
and the local community where marina
lives benefits too
i have a deal with the local village
elders that i will feed the 260 plus
children in the school
with meat from the hunt but in exchange
we have no perching or interference of
any kind
and it's a system that works it's all
about involving
local rural communities in benefiting
from the world
if communities don't benefit from the
wildlife there's little incentive to
look after it
living on this landscape is hard there's
not much
choices and this wildlife is wild
people romanticize that these animals
are beautiful they are beautiful animals
but they are also very dangerous
and they can kill people or they can
make our kids not go to school
if wildlife becomes an economic asset
people will want to protect it
rather than poach or kill it critics of
trophy hunting
say that it only benefits the privileged
in the country like marina
who operates a private farm but in
namibia and other countries
this is not always the case
nearly 20 of its land is run by local
communities
they choose how they want to use it
the communities use the land as farmers
so
they can be livestock owners they can be
crop growers
the conservancies choose to have trophy
handy it's also
benefiting them financially and that is
the only way that we can motivate these
communities
to be able to look after the lens for
conservation values at the moment
if trophy hunting is implemented well
and critically with the buying of local
and national
communities and governments you really
can see an increase in the wildlife
population
according to international data the only
african countries with increasing
populations of wild lions used trophy
hunting
including of lions as part of their
wildlife management
and back in namibia there were only 12
white rhinos in 1968 since trophy
hunting of them began in 1982
their numbers have rebounded and
valuable revenue has been raised for
their conservation
in order for countries to see these
results trophy hunting has to be well
implemented as it is in namibia
by law dan has to be accompanied by a
registered namibian professional hunter
his guide today is johnny
these are footprints you can see it's
very fresh it's early from this morning
only a maximum of two percent of certain
species can be killed in trophy hunting
and in many cases even less are taken
and there are strict government quotas
on which species of animal can be hunted
and for some species which sex for
trophy hunting
we don't shoot young animals because we
use the younger males for breeding
and big bulls they are not breeding the
bulls they don't breed anymore they just
eaten
they've been searching for an old oryx
bull for hours
namibia is a peaceful and reasonably
well-governed country
load up which is why trophy hunting can
be well managed here
but in other countries it's not so
simple
trading hunting is by no means a panacea
done badly
it can negatively affect animal
populations for instance around wangi
national park in zimbabwe
they had far too high quotas for male
lions there
it just was completely unsustainable
corruption can also be rife in some
countries
some estimate that across just seven
african countries
trophy hunting brings in more than 200
million dollars
a year but it's often unclear how much
reaches local stakeholders
yet in places where revenues do reach
local people
trophy hunting money is a financial
lifeline
for example in namibia the annual
revenue from hunting is 28.5 million
dollars
and in zimbabwe 770 000 households
benefit in some way from it
in many cases revenue from trophy
hunting can't be replaced
by other incomes there's a real
misconception that
photo tourism could easily be
substituted for trophy hunting in most
places and that's just not the case
for tourism you need stability you need
low disease risk you need infrastructure
you need
scenic areas with lots of wildlife in
many many hunting areas that's not the
case
in namibia frequent droughts make it
difficult for large tourist operations
but it's ideal terrain for hunters and
johnny has spotted some prey
hunting involves killing it's just a
necessary part of it
is that what i'm here for absolutely not
is it necessary absolutely soon
safety off safety off
you see between the trees
[Laughter]
he's down i didn't see it till the last
moment because
it was behind a tree but johnny knew it
was there it's a heart lung shot he went
right down with one shot
i've seen trophy photos which are
disrespectful of the animal
and i don't approve but that's not the
way we do it uh we
we respect the animal we honor it we use
every bit of it
so i think you can do it tastefully and
that's what we strive for
calls for trophy hunting bands are
intensifying
britain appears to be pushing ahead with
a ban on the import of trophies
and some american states have also
pushed for import bans
but blanket bans and restrictions are
not the answer
there is no conservation model in the
world that is perfect
and i will also not claim that ours is
perfect
over the years we have managed to bring
wildlife back
in areas in countries where it was
nearly decimated
i failed to understand why would you
like to
close down a really good model that
worked
for southern africa with no immediate
alternative
to trophy hunting vast areas of african
habitat
more than that covered by national parks
would be put at risk
when people look for a ban on trophy
hunting because they find it morally
unacceptable what is the alternative
that's going to be put in their place
and how is that viewed
at the country level in 2020
more than 50 african community leaders
signed an open letter
criticizing online influencers who call
for bans on trophy hunting
it's these local communities that have
to foot the bill for conservation
at the moment all the costs are born
locally and all the benefits generally
go internationally
i think we do need a new model of
conservation and one where the
international community plays a far more
active role in funding
the costs of conservation we cannot
expect the poorest people in the world
to maintain something that largely is
valued by the richest people in the
world
it is not a sustainable model and
crucially
local communities and conservationists
have to be listened to
rather than ignored or vilified africans
were born with wildlife they understand
wildlife
it is important that we listen to those
silent
community conservation voices the people
that are
impacted by wildlife
developing new solutions for
conservation could take years
and one million or more species are
facing extinction
now while trophy hunting is no silver
bullet
taking this conservation tool off the
table with no viable alternative
will place millions of acres of habitat
and the species that rely on it
at risk hi my name is katie bales i'm a
producer here at the economist
if you would like to learn more about
the threats to african wildlife please
click the link opposite
thanks for watching and don't forget to
[Music]
subscribe